Que ce soit pour trouver le film
qu'on va regarder ce soir,
le chemin le plus court
ou même trouver l'amour,
notre quotidien est de plus en plus
guidé par les algorithmes.
Dans ce monde
de plus en plus contrôlé par les algos,
la chasse à la transparence
risque d'être rude.
Et des projets
comme celui d'Edouard, Louis et Thomas
seront carrément les bienvenus.
Aujourd'hui, on part à leur rencontre
et ils vont nous montrer
comment les sites de réservation
d'hôtels manipulent nos recommandations.
Salut les gars.
Salut Antoine.
Vous bosser
sur la recommandation d'hôtels,
c’est super niche.
Qu'est-ce qui a fait
que vous êtes motivés à bosser
sur ce petit sujet précis ?
Alors nous, de base,
on est trois étudiants lyonnais
et si on veut venir à Paris par exemple,
on utilise des sites de
recommandations d'hôtels
pour réserver un hôtel.
Genre Booking.com quoi.
Exactement.
Et on se rend compte très vite
que sur ces sites là, c'est
les mêmes hôtels qui reviennent en haut
des recommandations.
C'est un peu tout le temps
les mêmes qu'on voit à chaque fois.
C'est
un peu tout le temps,
les mêmes qu'on voit
et on peut croire que ce sont
des recommandations optimales.
Mais ce n'est pas forcément le cas,
parce que certains hôtels payent
des commissions aux sites
pour pouvoir être plus mises
en avant que certains autres.
Donc un petit bakchich
et tu te retrouves en haut de la page.
On dirait une théorie du complot.
C'est vraiment comme ça que ça marche ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Sur les différents
sites de recommandation comme Booking.com
Hotel.com ou TripAdvisor,
on peut voir
dans les conditions générales
et le fonctionnement du site
que c'est marqué, par soucis de transparence,
que oui,
les établissements versent
une certaine commission
et selon le montant de la commission
qu'ils versent aux sites Internet,
ils seront
plus ou moins bien classés à chaque fois
sur les résultats.
Transparence, si c’est
un petit alinéa au fin fond
des conditions générales,
ce n'est pas non plus
le truc le plus transparent du monde.
C’est vrai,
pour un citoyen lambda,
c'est comme les conditions générales
ou les politiques de confidentialité
sur les contrats.
on ne les lit pas forcément.
Donc,
c'est un peu caché,
mais c'est quand même marqué
si on cherche un petit peu.
Et du coup,
comment est ce que je peux avoir
accès à des recommandations
qui ne sont pas biaisées ?
Donc, du coup, l’approche
qu'on a pris pour régler ce problème,
c'est qu'on a tout simplement créé
notre propre site
internet de recommandations d’hôtels.
Ah oui, vous êtes chaud,
tu peux me montrer ça ? Oui, bien sûr.
Alors nous, on a voulu une plateforme
qui soit ergonomique,
simple d'utilisation
et surtout 100%
transparente pour l'utilisateur.
C’est vrai que le site est clean.
Exactement.
On ne se perd pas.
Donc là je me connecte sur la plateforme
et donc on arrive sur la page d'accueil.
Donc en haut on peut voir un petit menu.
Et ce menu,
il va nous permettre
de choisir l'algorithme
qu'on veut pour notre recommandation.
C'est hyper ouvert,
c'est l'inverse de Booking.com,
les algorithmes sont complètement
transparents.
Exactement.
Ça te dit qu'on fasse un test ?
Bah oui, carrément,
j'ai envie de voir ça.
Quel est le dernier hôtel
que tu as aimé quand t'es venu à Paris ?
J'en sais rien,
mais là,
je vois un hôtel Edouard 7
dans tes recommandations
Et bah c'est parti.
Et donc là,
on arrive sur la page des recommandations.
Donc tu peux voir que l'avantage
de notre plateforme,
c'est qu'on affiche le score de matching
des différents hôtels.
Donc là, l'hôtel Edouard 7 et l'hôtel
Pont Royal, comme on le voit
ici, ont 90% de similarité
Donc tous ces pourcentages
c'est la similarité
entre cet ancien hôtel et tous ceux
qui, du coup pouvaient m'intéresser.
Si j'ai aimé le précédent,
je pourrais aimer ceux-là.
Exactement, t’as 90% de chance
d'aimer l'hôtel Pont Royal si t'as aimé
l'hôtel Edouard 7.
Trop bien, c’est génial
parce qu'en plus, c'est
hyper transparent.
Exactement.
J'imagine que pour faire ça,
il faut des données.
Elles viennent d'où tes données ?
Alors exactement
on a récupéré les données de TripAdvisor.
OK, mais ils te les ont donné comme ça, gratos ?
Alors non, on a utilisé une technique
qui s'appelle le Web Scraping.
En fait,
le Web Scraping, c'est
un petit robot
qui va chercher les informations
sur le site internet.
Tu as le droit ?
C'est pas du vol d'infos ?
Alors on l'a fait,
c'est totalement légal.
Il faut faire attention
en fonction des plateformes,
ça change un peu.
Il y a des plateformes
qui sont plus permissives que d'autres,
mais TripAdvisor l'est et c'est pour ça
qu'on a récupéré toutes les données
sur ce site là.
C'est ouf !
C'est une mine d'or pour vous,
sur des projets comme ça.
OK, donc vous avez toutes ces données,
mais comment vous en faites
un algorithme de recommandation concrètement ?
Pour faire un système de recommandation
précis et complet,
on a combiné plusieurs concepts.
On a combiné déjà
deux types de recommandation
la recommandation basée sur le contenu
qui va étudier la similarité
entre les différents hôtels
et la recommandation basée
sur le filtrage collaboratif
qui va étudier la similarité
entre des utilisateurs par exemple.
Ces deux types de recommandation
ont un point commun, c'est
que pour être mise en place,
elle demande toutes les deux
d'utiliser du Machine Learning.
Vous êtes peut être un petit peu perdu,
on va éclaircir tout ça.
Le taf des systèmes de recommandation,
c'est d'aider
les utilisateurs d'une plateforme
à déterminer
facilement ce qu'ils pourraient
apprécier au travers de suggestions
et pour nous suggérer des morceaux,
des films, des hôtels,
il y a plusieurs méthodes.
La méthode basée sur le contenu.
Ils nous en ont parlé.
Pour ça,
il faut que l'algo de
la plateforme étudie
les similarités
entre les différents éléments
de notre base de données,
que ce soit des films, des musiques
ou des hôtels.
Donc si par le passé
j'ai apprécié l'hôtel A,
que l'hôtel A ressemble à l'hôtel B,
alors l'algo
va me recommander l'hôtel B.
Pour évaluer la similarité
entre deux hôtels,
ce n'est pas trop difficile
parce qu'on peut se baser
sur des critères factuels :
la même taille de chambre,
la même gamme de prix
ou par exemple, s'ils sont pas loin
l'un de l'autre.
Mais pour du texte, par exemple,
c'est plus complexe de construire
cette matrice de similarité.
On pourrait utiliser des techniques
comme le TF-IDF, qui permet d'évaluer
l'importance d'un mot au sein
d'un texte
et d'en faire émerger des thèmes.
Bref, la recommandation sur le contenu,
c'est recommander du contenu
similaire à du contenu
qu'on a aimé par le passé.
Une seconde méthode
a une approche différente.
Elle est basée
sur le filtrage collaboratif.
Ici, rien à voir
avec la première méthode.
La plateforme ne se base pas
sur le contenu
pour faire ses suggestions,
mais elle se base directement sur nous,
les utilisateurs.
En gros,
elle va analyser mes comportements
et chercher d'autres utilisateurs
qui me ressemblent.
Par exemple, moi,
j'écoute pas mal de jazz sur Spotify
et les autres utilisateurs
qui écoutent
ce genre de jazz,
qui ont des habitudes similaires
aux miennes,
statistiquement,
ils aiment aussi écouter de l'indie,
donc, même si c'est
un style assez différent,
Spotify va me recommander
de l'indie
en se basant sur la similarité
entre les autres utilisateurs et moi.
Et puis,
il existe une troisième méthode,
c'est la méthode hybride.
Comme son nom l'indique,
le système hybride, c'est
un système qui regroupe
les deux approches décrites précédemment.
L'algorithme va prendre en compte
les caractéristiques de chaque hôtel
et les avis de chaque utilisateur.
En gros,
c'est le meilleur des deux mondes.
On a parlé de Machine Learning,
mais concrètement,
comment vous l'utilisez
pour faire des recommandations ?
On a utilisé plusieurs principes
du Machine Learning,
comme la recommandation basée sur le contenu que Louis t’as montré avant.
Et en gros,
on a fait une matrice,
un gros tableau de similarités
avec différentes caractéristiques
des hôtels
pour mettre en lumière
les scores de matching de chaque hôtel
par rapport à ses caractéristiques.
Donc en gros, pour chacune
des paires d'hôtels
possibles,
tu leur donne une note de similarité.
Tu mets tout ça dans un tableau,
mais tu te base sur
quelles caractéristiques
pour donner cette similarité ?
On s'est basé
sur différentes caractéristiques
qu'on a trouvé plus pertinentes,
comme par exemple le prix forcément,
ou la taille de l'hôtel
ou d'autres services
assez récurrents et importants
comme le petit déjeuner le matin
par exemple.
OK donc ça c'est
pour la recommandation de contenu.
Mais comment ça marche
pour le filtrage collaboratif ?
Alors comme l’a dit
Edouard, on va comparer du coup
les utilisateurs entre eux.
Alors là, du coup,
pour la présentation,
j'ai pris le soin de créer
trois profils existants.
Donc on a Lara, Lucie et Pierre.
Prenons Lucie par exemple.
Donc Lucie, on sait
qu'elle est allée à ces quatre hôtels là.
On sait qu'elle les a aimé, ces hôtels.
Donc l'algorithme,
il va s'occuper
de comparer cette liste là
et de trouver un utilisateur
qui a fait possiblement
les mêmes choix, c'est à dire
qu'il a possiblement aimé
ces hôtels là.
Et donc,
on peut voir en sortie d'algorithme
que ce sont ces trois hôtels là
qui sont sortis,
donc les plus similaires à l'utilisateur.
Donc ceux qui ont aimé ça,
ils ont aimé le Ritz Paris.
Donc tu lui dis,
tu vas probablement aimer le Ritz Paris.
Exactement.
Et on a mis le score possible
qu'elle mettrait
si elle visitait ces hôtels.
Donc là, c'est cinq étoiles,
mais c'est totalement paramétrable.
Tu penses qu'elle va vraiment mettre 5 étoiles ?
Je pense,
le Ritz, c'est quand même bien.
C'est cher mais c’est bien.
Ça fait quoi de vous dire
que les recommandations sont biaisées ?
Est-ce qu'il y a toujours
une petite étiquette sponsorisée ?
Parce que perso, j'ai l'impression
qu'on nous ment
en fait, si c’est pas clair.
Alors ça va dépendre des sites
sur lesquels on va se trouver.
Sur certains sites,
ce sera vraiment montré
explicitement et sur d'autres sites,
ce sera un peu plus discret.
Mais on se rend compte
que la recommandation pour les hôtels
est assez opaque, assez floue sur le Web.
On s'est alors
mis en quête d'explorer d'autres
systèmes de recommandations,
comme par exemple celui de Spotify
qu'on a pu analyser.
L'analyse qu'on a ressortie de Spotify,
c'est que pour me recommander
une chanson,
par exemple,
ça va utiliser les chansons
que j'ai déjà écouté,
les chansons que je mets
dans mes playlists,
l'heure à laquelle j'écoute mes chansons,
l'ordre dans lequel j'écoute
mes chansons,
les utilisateurs qui ont écouté
les mêmes chansons
que moi ou par exemple,
la couleur de mes chaussettes.
Il y a de tout quoi.
Je pense qu'il est important
que tous les utilisateurs,
et en particulier les plus jeunes
d'entre nous,
comprennent que quand il y a
une recommandation sur un site,
ce n'est pas du tout le fruit
d'un heureux hasard.
C'est vraiment un algorithme
qui a travaillé derrière et c'est
la plateforme
qui met en avant ces contenus.
Donc ça peut être quelque chose
de totalement positif
parce qu'on
peut trouver des objets
qui nous correspondent,
des choses
qui sont similaires à notre profil.
Mais il faut vraiment garder ça en tête
que ce n'est pas du hasard
et que c'est
proposé par la plateforme dans le but
de nous faire acheter un maximum.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
parce que tu vois par exemple
l’algorithme de recommandation Spotify,
moi, je l'adore.
J'ai découvert plein
de bonnes musiques grâce à ça,
mais au final, c'est un peu présenté,
parfois comme si c'était le choix
le plus optimal,
presque comme si c'était
un choix parfaitement objectif,
alors que au final,
il y a de l’humain derrière,
et c'est un choix
presque politique de dire
OK, on délègue ce choix là
à un algorithme de recommandation
plutôt qu'à du hasard.
OK, finalement,
ce que les gars ont fait en créant
leur propre site de réservation
d'hôtels, c'est proposer aux utilisateurs
une interface 100% honnête
afin de mettre en avant
les locations
qui correspondent
au mieux aux différents besoins
des utilisateurs.
On n'a pas un acteur extérieur
qui pourrait interférer
avec leurs score de matching
comme dans la plupart des autres
plateformes.
On le disait
en intro, aujourd'hui,
on se laisse véritablement bercé
au rythme des différents algorithmes.
Ils font tout le travail à notre place.
Alors, ce que proposent
Edouard, Louis et Thomas,
c'est plus que cool. Bravo les gars !
Merci Thomas,
Louis et Edouard
de m’avoir montré votre projet,
je vous souhaite tout
le meilleur pour la suite.
Voilà le genre de choses
que vous pourriez apprendre à l’ESME
dans la majeure
Intelligence Artificielle.
Pour en apprendre plus
sur les formations que propose l'école.
Rendez vous sur le site de l'ESME.
Pensez à vous abonner
à L'étincelle et nous,
on se retrouve très vite
pour des projets d'ingénierie,
encore plus dingues.
Post-traitement : OggiWan